with Jupiter ascending out now let's
look at 12 things you probably didn't
know about there chaski sci-fi adventure
Kane white means if and zoom about on a
pair of air surfing boots but in reality
actor Channing Tatum used a pair of
skates on a system of ramps platforms
and cables to give the feeling of
airborne movement with the help of six
men pulling wires behind a green screen
Tatum rollerbladed at four and a half
miles per hour on the giant three-sided
pred mill four meters long and two
meters wide of course the wheels of the
skates were erased during
post-production Pro inline skater Corey
Miller from California and vert skater
tied Chris from France helped train
Channing Tatum and the Jupiter ascending
stunt team Tatum had no previous
rollerblading experience and in the
beginning found it tough to skate fast
and still stop in time to throw or block
a punch but according to the actor he
started to get the hang of things when
he just kept his skates on all day tight
chris is best known for his 2010 drop
from the Eiffel Tower onto a vert ramp
which broke the world record for the
highest inline skate jump but he also
performed cane wide his leap from the
second floor balcony of the Great Hall
in the Natural History Museum which
doubled for colleagues Palace and he
flew through Erie Cathedral which
doubled as a chapel on Titus's ship cane
wise is a genetically engineered human
whose DNA was spliced with that of a
wolf director lana wachowski discovered
that real wolves hunt in packs and that
wolves exiled from the pack as Cain was
in Jupiter ascending almost always died
unless they become a super hunter Cain
splice of wolf DNA enhances his skills
and heightened--his senses over 1.3
million Swarovski crystals were used on
the film's costumes
Jupiter's white and Ruby gown for
example features hundreds of crystals as
well as handmade flowers and a headdress
of ruby flowers and more crystals also
3d printing was used to create both
Jupiter's headdress and some of the
jewellery seen in the movie
the movies first big action sequence
which begins at Chicago's Willis Tower
and darts under bridges and above the
city skyline is a blend of physical
stunts by the actors and stunt doubles
practical location shots visual effects
and green-screen stage work it took an
amazing 8 months of planning to carry
out the aerial work in that scene first
the Jupiter ascending crew perfected the
stunt choreography in the safe
environment of Warner Brothers Studios
and leave Sun in the UK after that they
did test runs in Long Beach California
to confirm that performers suspended
from helicopters could carry out a
series of flying poses while being
filmed by cameras positioned on other
helicopters once filming proper began
parts of downtown Chicago were closed in
the early morning and night for for two
weeks this was so that low-level
helicopters with Channing Tatum and Mila
Kunis's stunt double suspended from them
could fly around buildings while a
second helicopter film the action at the
same time a third helicopter filmed
background plates for the hundreds of
visual effect shots of downtown
Chicago's destruction on top of this
there were four camera crews on rooftops
along the route to capture additional
footage because big action chase scenes
are so complicated they're typically
shot in daylight or at night to give
filmmakers as much time as possible to
get all the shots they need however the
word chow skis wanted to film just
before sunrise to capture the unique
look and feel of that time of day that
meant their shoot had a very tight
schedule just 30 minutes from 5:15 a.m.
to 5:45 a.m. to be precise to capture
the best action shots on location the
movies visual effects supervisor dan
glass and cinematographer john toll
created a new six camera rig named a
panic cam which was fixed to a
helicopter this new rig captures super
wide angle views at very high
resolutions from many shots which the
crew later painted their CG images onto
CGT creature greeghan who's one of
balam's
deadly royal guards is a sort of seven
foot tall lizard with a 20 foot wingspan
and a whip-like tail to prepare for his
motion capture performers actor Aryan
Bukhari who portrays greeghan studied
the movements of lizards such as Komodo
dragons and aim to combine human
intelligence with a reptiles agility and
unpredictability the design of the
spaceships in Jupiter ascending was
influenced by the history of
Transportation and the fact that rich
people have always traveled in style
the Wachowski z' wanted to reflect this
by giving their spaceship a sense of
opulence they thought was generally
missing in sci-fi movies the film's
various spacecraft are sleek and agile
with designs inspired by nature for
example insects or birds of prey
production designer hue beta adapted the
hallways and display areas at London's
Natural History Museum to create the set
of colleagues Palace later gilded domes
and spires were added digitally the
chapel scene on Titus's ship was filmed
at Ely Cathedral in Cambridgeshire
England production designer hubei tup
combined the cathedral sandstone gothic
features with modern steel framed
windows structures and light fixtures
created by set decorator Peter Walpole
and the prop Department as for the
overall look of Titus's home that was
influenced by variety of styles
including gothic and Art Deco
architecture as well as the huge pillars
of Old English churches and the wood
finishes in brass or gold trim of mid
19th century luxury yachts balam's home
is a vast space which includes a lab and
refinery and brings to mind both a steel
mill and a supercollider to create that
world the crew constructed enormous sets
at Leavesden studios and the visual
effects team surrounded those sets with
floor-to-ceiling green screens balam's
world is a spin on gothic and industrial
styles with added opulence
well there you have it 12 things you
probably didn't know about Jupiter
ascending
tell me what's your favorite sci-fi
movie if you enjoyed this video hit the
thumbs up button and subscribe for more
things you didn't know plus weekly movie
reviews and interviews thanks for
watching
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers